now we begin with breaking news from the
International Court of Justice at The
Hague it's ruled in favor of Qatar in a
dispute with four Arab countries that
have imposed a blockade in the Gulf
state and have prevented Qatar the
aircraft from flying over their airspace
the court said the UN Civil Aviation
agency has jurisdiction in this case the
call one unanimous rejected the appeal
brought by the Kingdom of Bahrain they
are a republic of Egypt the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia and the United Arab
Emirates - by 15 votes to one hold that
the Council of the International Civil
Aviation Organization has jurisdiction
to entertain the application submitted
to it by the government of the state of
other on 30 October 2017 and that the
same application is admissible well it
all began in June 2017 in Saudi Arabia
the UAE Bahrain and Egypt severed ties
with Qatar and imposed a land sea and
air blockade Doha then called in the
International Civil Aviation
Organization to declare the air blockade
illegal but the blockading countries
challenged that move suggesting the UN
agency didn't have jurisdiction to
handle the dispute won in 2018
the agency rejected that claim insisting
that it does have jurisdiction the move
in Qatar favor the blockading countries
then turned to the International Court
of Justice asking it to re-examine the
issue of jurisdiction it's now ruled in
Qatar favor once again it paves the way
for doha to possibly sue the blockading
countries for compensation or find other
ways to end the air blockade now Saudi
Arabia the UAE Bahrain and Egypt accused
Kato's government of supporting
terrorism allegations without evidence
that Doha has strongly denied the air
restrictions imposed three years ago
affected several major flight routes
that passed through the airspace of the
blockading nations it forced Qatar
Airways to make
longer details and use limited alternate
flight paths kata says the airspace
restrictions by Saudi Arabia and the UAE
are a clear violation of international
law
now step Vasan has been covering this
story for us at The Hague and she's
joining us live this was an extremely
complex case step if you can't just talk
us through what was happening in court
well legal experts here call it a very
confident verdict in the sense that it
was a very clear verdict I think many
here had expected that some of the
appeal might have been rejected and
might not have been rejected it comes
down to two cases that have been filed
by the four countries against Qatar it
deals with a Chicago Convention from
1944 but also an air surfaces transit
agreement also signed in 1944 both
agreements deal with the same issue
which is a freedom of movement between
countries in airspace so basically a
country is allowed to fly into another
country's airspace exactly as Qatar has
wished would happen so Qatar as you said
has filed this case at the I ICAO a
council and the countries have appealed
against this verdict now the president
has explained at length that the Chicago
Convention signed by most nations are in
the world that this is a very right
convention to use that it deals exactly
with this issue that cotta is dealing
with now because the four countries had
said it wasn't the case they said this
isn't a security issue dealing with
terrorism it has nothing to do with
aviation so the president has made clear
that it has to do with aviation also
another appeal a part of the appeal was
about the negotiations they the
countries had accused Qatar of not doing
enough to come to a diplomatic
settlement before taking the the case to
the ICAO Council now the president here
at the court has decided that Qatar did
everything it could to to make all the
diplomatic efforts possible to avoid
going to the ICAO Council
until the last minute the president said
but it was very clear that the countries
were unwilling to reach this settlement
so on all accounts this appeal was
rejected it means now that the ball is
back with the ICAO counsel who now has
to really go into the content of the
case and make a ruling about this air
blockade so experts here are telling me
this could unfortunately still take a
couple of years but now for now of
course this is a very positive outcome
for Qatar that's that vas in life for us
in The Hague I want to talk to Al
Jazeera's senior political analyst
Marwan Machado who is here with us in
Doha the obvious question of course
Marwan is what does this mean for the
eventual lifting of the blockade because
this was always seen as a key step in
that as we've heard from our
correspondent it's a it's going to be a
question of time and usually with
international organizations with you and
organization it's quite difficult to
usually in terms of a frustrating
process moving forward because the
bureaucracy is quite cumbersome and
usually states have lots of leverage now
whether I can would actually be able to
enforce the thing sooner than later
remains to be seen but the fact that
Saudi Arabia they are members of the
International Civil Aviation
Organization it means that eventually
they're gonna have to come to terms with
its ruling and that actually goes to a
lot of other aspects to this conflict
here in the region but Abu Dhabi and
Riyadh have been adamant they have been
stubborn they have failed to admit their
failure if you well and hence they won't
even accept a trump administration
initiative you know that sit down with
the Qataris and figure this thing out on
the basis of an American initiative all
in all this was an important cornerstone
an important day and the fact that one
core one.you unarmed told the UAE and
Saudi Arabia that another rear a arm
that is already seen this brief
to be to have the jurisdiction to rule
on it I think that's that's that's huge
that's important but as you said we're
gonna have to wait and see how does this
reflect on other aspects one of the the
key elements of the ruling that the
court made was the fact that in the
initial representations there had been
apparently no effort on negotiation on
the part of Saudi Arabia the UAE Bahrain
and Egypt in order for this to progress
is there is there any hope do you think
that some sort of negotiation might open
up and that might lead to a path towards
more talks just to remind our viewers
around the world that the blockading
countries imposed 13 conditions or
rather preconditions for sitting down
with the Catalans and as and almost
everyone in the trans community
including fairest London on Washington
that to look that these conditions have
said you know and the in the words of
their in foreign foreign minister or
Secretary of State
tell arson that this were basically
ridiculous that they were not
enforceable not realistic and so and so
forth and just to again to remind our
viewers around the world is that one of
those conditions was closing our own
network al Jazeera that is based in
Qatar so really the idea that that Qatar
could have negotiated with these
countries when these countries have put
precondition that basically our
surrender makes it all you know too
unrealistic to blame Qatar for not
government any questions that's one - I
think what we've heard the last few days
about an American initiative to bring
the parties together you know on the
basis of something that's reasonable
pragmatic that was rejected according to
Fox News the American president's
favorite network that was rejected by
the UAE in particular that convinced all
you're able to walk away from the
America initiative that really tells us
that the lucky the countries feel
uncomfortable evening sitting down with
their you know favorite Ally the United
States uh Trump administration in order
to figure this thing out clearly and in
some after three years of failures
it seems that Abu Dhabi and Riyadh are
finding it ever too difficult to just
admit their mistakes admit their failure
and try to work for a better future for
this region and and for this golf is
there any suggestion Marwin that this
ruling given the fact that as you say
that we have to be aware that these
things do take time particularly with it
with international law at the same time
this ruling does give a degree of
leverage on the part of Qatar in terms
of strengthen the amount of
international opinion if you like with
regard to whether or not the blockade
should be withdrawn absolutely and you
know so you know I'm completely open
about this I I myself had to get some
legal advice if you will about the legal
aspect of this thing because I had
definitely understand the political
implications and why this is a very
important step forward for Qatar in
terms of you know unblocking if you will
the blockade but clearly the fact that
Saudi Arabia UAE Bahrain and Egypt are
part of ICAO they are part of the
international civil administration
organization it means that they can have
to abide by stools
the fact that they tried to escape that
by running away to the International
Criminal Court of course Court of
Justice did not add much to their
gimmicks and then the other day this has
really blown up on their faces it went
back to the International Civil
Administration and we know where it's
leaning so now the question is whether
they will preempt any punitive action on
the part of you that the various UN arms
ordered attacks or whether they will
wait until they are totally embarrassed
you know with the total dress-down by
the United Nations various forms for
them to do something I suggest
and seems like everyone else are just
around the world is that Saudi Arabia
and he needs to get with the program
they need to really admit their failure
they need to listen to the United
Nations Civil Aviation or International
Court of Justice and just basically lift
the blockade because it is really a
waste of time waste of energy and
frankly it's a wisdom it's a lot of
global warming for all these airplanes
that just have to go through over Iran
and order to go back south and so on and
so forth it's just been a terrible three
years it will be great for everyone if
they just listen to the International
Criminal Court if they would listen to
the National Secular affiliation and
accept the ruling and lift the blockade
so I'll just hear a senior political
analyst Marwan Bashar Amman thank you
very much indeed